[Música]
27 personas murieron en Perú luego de
que se desencadenará un incendio en una
mina de oro es el accidente más
mortífero que ha habido dentro de una
Mina en más de dos décadas y los
familiares de las víctimas buscan
información
Turquía está a una semana de las
elecciones presidenciales que se
realizarán el 14 de mayo Aunque el
presidente
arrancó como el gran favorito y podría
prolongar su mandato a más de 10 años
consecutivos los opositores toman fuerza
Aunque la coronación del Rey Carlos
tercero fue el sábado más de 24 horas
después los británicos siguen celebrando
hay picnics y un concierto en el Palacio
de Windsor comentaremos el evento con
nuestra periodista marinas ardilla
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
yo soy María Clara calle
iniciamos con noticias de nuestra región
en Perú hubo un incendio en una mina de
oro hasta ahora el gobierno local de
yanaquigua ha reportado 27 fallecidos y
la policía sostiene que el fuego fue
causado por un corto circuito dentro de
un túnel en la mina Ama al benzman nos
cuenta
familiares de Mineros esperan ansiosos
información en el exterior de la mina de
oro la esperanza en la región de
Arequipa al sur de Perú allí 27
trabajadores murieron en un incendio
en un total de
48 personas no a la unidad no es una
noche en donde lamentablemente no hemos
perdido a 27 personas no una cifra
confirmada por el gobierno de Perú
expresamos nuestras condolencias a los
familiares y al pueblo de Arequipa por
la muerte de los 27 mineros hecho
ocurrido en el sector de yanaquiwa
provincia de condesuyos en Arequipa un
cortocircuito habría causado la tragedia
imágenes difundidas en redes sociales
mostraron una gran columna de humo
proveniente de la mina mientras medios
locales indicaron que en el momento del
corto circuito había personal trabajando
a unos 80 metros de profundidad el
sector minero es uno de los principales
pilares de la economía peruana ya que
representa 8,3% del producto interno
bruto el país es el segundo productor
mundial de cobre plata y zinc y el
primer productor de oro de América
Latina este tipo de incidente no es
excepcional en este país en 2020 cuatro
mineros quedaron atrapados en el
derrumbe de una mina artesanal también
en la región de Arequipa ya se están
contando los votos en chile para decidir
Quiénes conformarán el consejo
constitucional que será el encargado de
presentar el segundo borrador de la
Constitución para analizar el tema nos
acompaña desde Viña del Mar Guillermo
holmesmann él es analista político y
docente Guillermo Gracias por estar con
nosotros empecemos por explicar A qué se
debe la apatía de los votantes
primero porque se trata de un segundo
proceso Constituyente habiendo fracasado
el anterior cuya propuesta de
Constitución fue rechazada por un 62% de
ahí en adelante ha sido el congreso y
los partidos políticos los que han
apoyado la idea de un nuevo proceso
Constituyente para superar una crisis
político institucional que se espera sea
solucionada con una nueva carta
fundamental en esa perspectiva en el día
de hoy y se lleva a cabo yo diría el
tercer trámite de lo que es el inicio
este proceso que es la elección de los
consejeros constituyentes anteriormente
se designó parte del Congreso el comité
de expertos que va a entregar un
bordador de Constitución a este consejo
electo y también un
un comité de admisibilidad que tiene que
tiene por función velar porque doce
principios constitucionales que aprobó
el congreso y que deben estar
necesariamente la nueva carta
fundamental efectivamente se ha cumplido
y sea respetado por la instancia electa
en el día de hoy del Consejo
constitucional como usted bien lo
explicó el comité de expertos es el que
redacta el borrador constitucional Y
además ya hay unos doce principios que
sí o sí deben estar dentro de la Carta
Magna teniendo todo esto en cuenta que
tanta libertad entonces tendrá el
consejo constitucional
sería bastante libertad Porque primero
trabaja sobre un texto que le es
propuesto donde no está aquí a la
experiencia anterior si bien es cierto
no está incorporada institucionalmente
pero también Es evidente de que esa
experiencia digamos ha establecido de
que tiene cambio y transformación el
consejo constitucional no solamente va a
tomar el borrador que puede modificar
puede incluso eliminar alguna de las
propuestas Ah y a su vez también debe
administrar la participación ciudadana
de la cual es cuatro vías que el consejo
constitucional debe hacerse cargo tanto
que va desde digamos una propuesta
Popular de Norma hasta la posibilidad de
hacer cabildos y en ese en ese esquema
se va a producir el debate
constitucional que Esperamos sea
bastante intenso considerando las
enmiendas propuestas al comité de
expertos y que seguramente se van a
repetir El Siete de junio cuando se ha
instalado el consejo constitucional y
después de estos debates que sin duda
continuarán los chilenos volverán a
votar un referendo en diciembre de 2023
para aprobar o rechazar el borrador de
Constitución Qué diferencias habrá entre
esa votación y la del referendo del año
pasado que se perdió
Yo diría que las diferencias digamos en
el punto de vista electoral o
publicitario no son muchas porque se
convoca a toda la ciudadanía con voto
obligatorio para que apruebe o rechace
lo que es la propuesta que haga el
consejo constitucional es sin embargo no
está asegurada que estaba ya sea
aprobada como tampoco se puede afirmar
que hay vaya a ser rechazada va a
depender específicamente de lo que haga
este consejo constitucional en los
cuatro meses que tiene para poder llevar
una propuesta concreta a ser presentada
a la ciudadanía
Es evidente de que si se aprueban la
crisis política institucional que llevó
a cabo este proceso obviamente se va a
superar y Tendremos una nueva Carta
Magna pero si se rechazase probablemente
estaríamos en una profundización de la
crisis política que ha tenido chile
desde el 2019 en adelante Guillermo
osman gracias por su análisis
No gracias a ti María
ahora hacemos un breve recorrido por lo
que está pasando con decenas de
migrantes alrededor del mundo
115 venezolanos fueron repatriados desde
Chile en un avión humanitario que envió
el gobierno de Venezuela ellos estaba
varados en la frontera entre Perú y
chile desde que Lima decretó el estado
de emergencia ante el aumento de la
migración algo que ocurrió hace dos
semanas
en Texas Estados Unidos un hombre
atropelló a varias personas a las
afueras de un refugio de migrantes en
Brownsville 7 murieron y otras más
quedaron heridas la mayoría de las
víctimas son venezolanos y el conductor
fue detenido
más de 1400 migrantes llegaron al puerto
italiano de la pelusa en las últimas 24
horas con ellas en los centros de
acogida ya hay 1700 personas cuando la
capacidad máxima es de 400 y a casi 400
migrantes llevaron empujes a tres
albergues en la isla de sicilia
ahora hablemos de la actualidad de la
guerra en Ucrania el ejército de este
país advirtió que los rusos están
evacuando a sus ciudadanos que viven
cerca de la central nuclear de saporilla
una ciudad que controlan parcialmente
según los militares los rusos
trasladaron a las poblaciones a dos
sitios en la costa del mar de asoff
Mientras tanto por su lado Rusia señaló
que destruyó 32 drones ucranianos en un
intento por controlar la ciudad de
falta una semana para las elecciones
presidenciales de Turquía y que son
catalogadas como las más importantes de
los tiempos modernos Esto se debe a que
por un lado el actual presidente regieta
iberhoan quiere superar la década en el
poder pero del otro lado el principal
candidato de la oposición que mal kush
darobo lidera algunas encuestas veamos
a una semana de las elecciones que mal
calix dar Blue celebró uno de sus
mítines más multitudinarios hasta la
fecha y mantienen una sólida posición
para hacerse con las riendas del poder
político en Turquía y posiblemente gane
a una segunda vuelta contra el actual
presidente reyeta allí Perdón
quiero que sepan que abordaremos los
problemas de todos no discriminaré de
ningún modo abrazaré a los 85 millones
de turcos independientemente del partido
la identidad o las creencias
alguna vez pareció impensable que Eduard
pudiera ser derrocado del poder en la
presidencia desde 2014 y Primer Ministro
durante la década anterior la crisis
económica
erosionado su popularidad han pasado
años y mira cómo está el país la gente
ni siquiera puede permitirse beber té ya
no es como antes durante la campaña
electoral erdoan ha reconocido el estrés
económico del pueblo Turco afirmando que
solo él puede lograr el crecimiento del
país
compensaremos estas pérdidas económicas
con todas las mejoras que hemos
introducido en los salarios de nuestros
empleados y jubilados además de la mala
situación económica el gobierno ha
recibido críticas tras los dos
terremotos masivos de febrero en los que
murieron más de 50.000 personas el 14 de
mayo también está en juego los escaños
parlamentarios y los expertos políticos
afirman que hay mucho sobre la mesa no
solo quien dirigirá Turquía sino Qué
papel desempeñará en la escena mundial
Siria regresa a la liga árabe después de
haber sido suspendido del colectivo en
2011 los delegados de la liga se
reunieron en El Cairo Egipto y allí
decide decidieron readmitir al gobierno
de bachar al azar a pesar de que cuando
inició la Guerra Civil en ese país lo
apartaron por su violenta represión
contra los manifestantes
antigubernamentales Estados Unidos
respondió y dice que se opone al
reingreso Rafael Pérez con los detalles
tras 12 años de suspensión Siria es
readmitida en la liga árabe la decisión
fue tomada a Puerta cerrada por los
ministros de exteriores de los países
miembros del organismo el reingreso vino
acompañado entre otros aspectos de un
llamado de atención a los actores del
conflicto interno sirio para resolver la
crisis
es necesario defender el concepto de una
patria integral y segura y el
cumplimiento de cada uno de los
componentes del gobierno sirio las
fuerzas nacionales la comunidad
internacional y los países interesados
con sus obligaciones hacia los demás
para que Siria vuelva a los sirios
unificada estable e independiente
la resolución no contó con un respaldo
unánime varios estados entre ellos Qatar
se oponen a una reapertura con Damasco
sin tener sobre la mesa una solución
política en este sentido se creará una
comisión conformada por varias naciones
y el secretario general de la liga para
buscar soluciones a la guerra civil
el regreso de Siria es el comienzo de un
movimiento no el final la dirección de
la resolución de la crisis llevará
tiempo para que se apliquen los
procedimientos será gradual la tarea de
esta comisión es hacer seguimientos de
estos procedimientos el gobierno sirio
reaccionó con un pedido el desarrollo de
un enfoque efectivo basado sobre el
respeto mutuo entre los estados miembros
de la liga árabe Siria fue expulsada en
el año 2011 tras la represión de las
fuerzas del orden contra las protestas
que pedían un cambio de gobierno
los manifestantes reclamaban El Fin Del
mandato de la familia al azar tras 40
años en el poder
los británicos tuvieron un Big lange o
un gran almuerzo para continuar los
festejos la coronación de Carlos III y
para hablar de este tema nos acompaña de
nuestros estudios en Bogotá nuestra
periodista Marina sardilla Marina
bienvenida Hola María Clara
efectivamente hoy los británicos
continuaron con estas festividades
después de un evento masivo y
masivamente seguido y tuvieron la suerte
de su lado el sol brilló hoy en Londres
donde miles de personas se unieron al
tradicional gran almuerzo una fiesta
para acercar la monarquía a la Gran
Bretaña moderna anécdota hay un plato
honorífico declarado como comida oficial
del evento la Kiss de la coronación una
tarta salada horneada con espinacas
habas y estragón no todos comieron este
plato y las calles se llenaron también
de barbacoas Incluso el Primer Ministro
británico
risie sunak ofreció un almuerzo en su
despacho en el número 10 de downing
Street al que invitó a refugiados
ucranianos los miembros de la familia
real acudieron a un concierto vespertino
en el castillo de Windsor destinado a
unas 20.000 personas e invitados de
honor y que tuvo como actuaciones a Katy
Perry y Andrea Bocelli entre otros junto
a los almuerzos callejeros y el
concierto no podría faltar el teatro
popular y un show de iluminación de la
nación con láses y drones que alumbrarán
los edificios más icónicos de Reino
Unido bueno y un dato y la Quiche que es
el plato típico en estos festejos
británicos paradójicamente es francesa
no es así así es verdad Bueno cuéntenos
entonces de dónde surgen estas
festividades Más allá de la disputa por
la Quiche Bueno después de las penurias
y las tragedias de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial las fiestas en la calle se
convirtieron en una de las principales
características de la coronación de la
Reina Isabel II en
1953 y en estas celebraciones
posteriores también en honor a la reina
como el jubileo de platino el año pasado
se realizan con el fin de mantener ese
espíritu vecindal ya sea en un té o con
el típico Fish and chip Este sí un plato
británico si bien esos encuentros
populares tienen éxito también hay un
lado oscuro que resaltan aquellos que se
oponen a la monarquía británica debido
al altísimo coste de la coronación que
superará los 100 millones de libras en
un momento de crisis económica y termino
con otra anécdota María Clara porque no
hay que escatimar estos los que están
celebrando en las festividades no
escatimarán en cerveza porque mañana es
declarado como festivo Perfecto entonces
para pasar la resaca no es así es bueno
y también hemos cubierto ampliamente las
detenciones de los grupos
antimonárquicos porque esto es mientras
unos festejan otros se oponen a que la
monarquía continúe en Reino Unido por
ahora nosotros despedimos en las
noticias Gracias Marina por estar con
nosotros y a ustedes los dejamos con
imágenes de la celebración de los
británicos
[Música]